There's so many tough,
frustrating,
crazy,
ridiculous things about learning Chinese characters and Japanese Kanji.
I know I've already shared some,
but just one more
before you can even read or write a basic sentence in mandarin or Japanese or if
for some reason you just really want to get crazy into medieval Korean or old
Vietnamese,
you need to know symbol after symbol.
So when I set out to learn symbol after hundreds of symbols,
I already knew I was in for it.
And then when I learned about the different pronunciations,
the meanings,
the systems in the subsystems within the characters,
it just threw me a Kaji,
punched the face and then the gut and then the face again,
just for good measure.
But I was really caught off guard by a killer Hawn below that almost knocked me
right out.
And that killer blow was all about the way you have to write each character.
It started innocently enough,
they taught me a handful of easy characters and how to write three or four
strokes in each.
So stroke one,
no,
wrong stroke one
stroke too.
No,
no,
no.
This is stroke too.
Okay.
Stroke three good.
You're getting it.
And stroke for as my sensei used to say almost.
Okay.
Congratulations.
You just wrote the character for day.
You're an honor.
A calligrapher under the next one.
One just like before too.
Oh wait.
Uh,
that goes over and down again,
right?
Yeah.
There it is.
Three.
Nope.
Okay,
fine.
Three,
four,
five.
Okay.
There's kind of a pattern here,
so at this point I'm starting to think it's just their form of good penmanship.
Sure.
It's all number Leonne orderly in sequential,
but I'm game there.
What a game it is.
This is not just good writing like in western calligraphy.
As I go along,
I learned that this is actually a basic part of writing the characters.
If you don't know the stroke orders,
you just plain don't know how to write.
That's it.
So like this one followed by this one,
followed by this one to make a box.
That's the right way to do it.
This one goes up,
not down.
This one has a swishy tail.
Make these lines before these ones,
but then do these other ones after this part.
This character has six strokes.
Not For and this character has 20 strokes,
not 21 don't miss any of these up.
All right,
we are watching you.
Fortunately I think to myself,
hey self,
I've already spotted some patterns.
I test those patterns out and what a relief.
I ended up getting good mileage out of some of them.
It got to the point where once I saw this,
but then soon I saw this after training young one.
You can see it too,
but there was more beneath the surface for one thing and you had to see this
coming patterns can change the left side.
Downstroke plus right side,
right plus downstroke starter Combo played like a drum beat in my head,
leaving me with a false sense of security.
So I fell victim to characters that split and reordered those same angles.
Oh Song.
You are a beautiful melody,
but you are a nasty character.
And even when rote formulas worked for one character,
they broke when more strokes were thrown into the mix.
Remember that Rice Patty from earlier,
it gets written one way on its own,
but another way is part of the character for hometown and in China that's not
even the right rice patty.
They switch up these two strokes.
If you're in China,
don't mix them up.
So yes,
stroke orders can change for the same character in different combinations and
yes,
stroke orders for the same character can differ between China and Japan.
It might not be the order of the strokes that changes either.
The first time I noticed this was the character for equipment,
it's big line gets attached and China and then the one for copy had a roof,
but as missing the normal top dot that every other roof I was familiar with has,
and there's a newer way to write this character and an older way.
In Japan there are new characters with fewer strokes and older characters with
more strokes.
And in China,
they're simplified characters that often have a lot fewer strokes,
but the fewer stroke characters in China aren't the same ones you'll find in
Japan.
Say even the patterns I thought I was seeing before turned out not to be hard
and fast rules,
but keen observer that you are.
Maybe you can step back and notice something that I didn't.
These are all straight lines,
stroke patterns.
It's just the direction,
the order that we're squabbling over here.
And that's true until you meet cursive scripts and other ways of writing.
The characters that have whimsical,
swishes and circles hits a lot to take in.
But it's important.
There is a right way and there is a wrong way.
And people will notice if you write the wrong way.
But you know what?
Millions upon millions of humans learned to write this way.
Ridiculous.
Yes,
but I never said it was impossible,
but what do you think?
Lay It on me in the comments and stick around at subscribe for language.